الثال الثالوث النووي مصطلح اشعل التوتر
من جديد في اوكرانيا بعد ان تعهد الرئيس
الروسي بتطويره للحفاظ على سياده روسيا
ووحده اراضيها
هذا المصطلح اثار تكهنات عده في الاوساط
السياسيه لما قد يشكله من تهديد للعواصم
الغربيه ففي العقيده العسكريه الروسيه
يتكون الثالث النووي من ثلاثه انواع من
الاسلحه الردعيه هذه الاسلحه تحمل رؤوسا
نوويه مهمتها الردع الاستراتيجي الشامل
ارضا وجوا وبحرا
كما كان الوضع من قبل سوف نلهتماما
متزايدا لتقويه الثالوث النووي وسنواصل
الانتاج الضخم لانظمه كنجال الجويه التي
تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ومن البحر سنبدا
في الامداد بكميات كبيره من صواريخ سيركون
والسلاح الاول منها هو الصاروخ سارمات
الارضي الذي يحمل عشره رؤوس نوويه وهو
نظام صاروخي استراتيجي من الجيل الخامس
ويتم استخدامه من قواعد ارضيه لضرب اهداف
على بعد الاف الكيلومترات باستخدام انواع
مختلفه من الوسائل الثابته والمتحركه
اما السلاح الثاني فهو مجمع صواريخ كنجال
الجويه التي تفوق سرعه الصوت والتي تعتبر
ايضا من احدث الاسلحه التي طورتها موسكو
ضمن الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تطلق من
الجو
حيث تبلغ سرعه هذا الصاروخ 12 الف كيلو
متر في الساعه وهو قادر على تدمير الاهداف
بمدى يصل الى 200 كيلو متر واخيرا سلاح
التسيركون البحري الذي يعد اخطر اسلحه
ثالث الردع النووي والذي لقب بالصاروخ
الذي لا يقهر حيث تكمن خطورته في الغواصات
التي تحمل والتي يمكنها التخفي في اعماق
البحار لاشهر قبل ان تطلق صواريخها كما
انه قادر على الوصول الى سرعه تساوي تسعه
ارقام ماخ ويبلغ مدى اكثر من الف كيلو متر
لا يقتصر الامر عند هذا الحد فروسيه تمتلك
ايضا انواعا مختلفه من السفن والغواصات
الحربيه المزوده بصواريخ نوويه عابره
للقارات والتي قد تلحق دمرا هائلا بشواطئ
العدو
ومنشاته الساحليه سلطان العيبان العربيه